are you excited yet we hope you're we
think you should be just look at all of
these pictures of Google data centers
all the Google services run on the
infrastructure that you see and with the
Google cloud platform and App Engine
this infrastructure is also available to
you that means that the code you create
in this course will execute alongside
all of the other Google services and can
leverage from the same scale security
and performance that Google has built
out over the years we can't wait to get
started and have you on your way to
write and deploy your own code into
these data centers on your journey to
writing scalable applications in the
Google cloud